à soir
on a tous un jeu qui nous a marqués de
part son scénario son gameplay ou encore
sa bande son le tout réuni cela crée un
véritable chef-d'oeuvre
et pour moi the last of us en est un
c'est un jeu post apocalyptique en mode
survie à la troisième personne
nous incarnons joël un perte d'une
trentaine d'années qui perdu sa fille
suite à la folie des hommes pendant le
développement de la maladie du corps 17
l'infection qui touche le cerveau est
transformé personnes en une sorte de
zombie appelé infectés nous retrouvons
joël vingt ans plus tard âgées de 50 ans
et qui dans ce monde anarchiste effectué
des transferts de marchandises avec
l'aide de son ami tu est cependant un
groupe nommé les lucioles dirigé par
incertaine marlène et said entre
guillemets sauver l'humanité et fera
appel à joël était ce pour transférer en
dehors de la ville
une marchandise plutôt bizarre cette
marchandise c'est elie une jeune fille
de 14 ans immunisé contre la maladie du
cordyceps beaucoup de péripéties se
passeront est l'objet de plusieurs
débats se feront ressentir
et voici donc trois théories que je vous
propose
ce dont je vais vous parler fait l'objet
de nombreux débats et cette théorie est
100% personnel et ne reflète que mon
avis je vous demanderai donc d'être
ouvert à cela
joël est un personnage particulier nous
avons face à nous une sorte d'anti héros
c'est à dire qu'il ne correspond pas aux
principes que l'on qualifierait de
héroïque il est vieux ferme agressif il
a tué beaucoup d'innocents ou de
survivant il faut pas oublier que joël
détient ce rôle de héros de l'humanité
soit le fait de transférer elie aux
lucioles
par défaut il n'était pas destiné à le
faire à la base
et pourtant tout repose sur ses épaules
pour les personnages du jeu comme pour
les joueurs
depuis presque le début du jeu le seul
but du joueur est d'emmener elie à
l'abattoir pour le bien de l'humanité et
la fin nous montrent autre chose mais
pourquoi
naughty dog par le biais de the last of
us a souhaité montrer comment se
comporteraient l'humanité en cas
d'épidémie d'infecter simplement appeler
le cordyceps et il faut avouer que leur
vision des choses pourraient bien
arriver
l'instinct de survie et le sens
principal de ce nouveau monde chacun
pense à lui même contrairement à joël
tout son épopée il n'a pas pensé à lui
et cela lui a coûté la vie de plusieurs
de ses proches comme sarah ou encore
tess en une année a côtoyé elie je pense
sincèrement que joël avions élit sa
fille sarah décédé lors du prologue et
pour une fois il a voulu penser à lui et
être heureux en vivant avec est lié à
ses côtés et ce peu importe l'avenir de
l'humanité
il n'est en aucun cas dit que l'antidote
qui est située dans le cerveau des limes
marche à 100 % et les fort probable
qu'ils ralentissent le processus de
transformation seulement et je pense que
joël l'a compris pourquoi vouloir sauver
une humanité qui est déjà réduite à tuer
tout ce qui bouge
qu'est ce qu'il se passerait si
d'antidote marcherait il ne faut pas
oublier que les lucioles se proclament
comme sauveur de l'humanité
alors vous imaginez s'il détenait le
vaccin ultime marlène s'en servirait
pour gouverner tout simplement et j'en
viens au mot principal de cette théorie
l'égoïsme nous parlons de survie soit de
l'égoïsme penser à soi avant tout pour
vivre
quoi qu'il arrive tu trouves toujours
une bonne raison d'être
joël l'a compris en sauvant elie la joie
le bonheur tout ce qui compose la vie
c'est pourquoi se bat joël il a pensé à
lui à son bonheur personnel et pour lui
son bonheur de passer sa vie avec elie à
ses côtés n'est ce pas merveilleux
la société actuelle the rest of us et la
survie à tout prix et joël a finalement
compris que pour survivre en étant
heureux
il fallait penser à soi c'est pourquoi
ils ne souhaitent pas en refaire la même
erreur qu'avec sahara et sauve donc elie
d'ailleurs pour finir sur cette théorie
je sais que beaucoup de personnes ne
parlerons kelly avait choisi de mourir
mais elle n'a rien choisi du tout
d'après moi la meilleure amie délire
riley était une luciole elie en était
amoureuse suite à la mort de son amie
elle a rejoint les lucioles et ceci
découvrant l'immunité des lits l'ont
influencé elle n'a que 14 ans à partir
du moment où elle a rencontré marlène
celle ci l'a éduqué avec l'idée de
sauver l'humanité et donc de se
sacrifier pour les autres elle n'avait
confiance quand marlène sa seule
connaissance marlène a voulu se servir
d'elle pour avoir l'antidote et régner
sur ce monde détruit
on note d'ailleurs kelly n'a jamais le
choix dans le jeu on ne lui propose même
pas d'annuler l'opération si elle le
souhaitait elle est orientée depuis le
début à se sacrifier pour le monde
qu'en pensez vous le monde a pris sahara
à joël joël appris et lit avec
l'antidote au monde
the last of us 2 est en développement
cela a été confirmé par nolan north
l'acteur de nathan drake le personnage
principal de uncharted
il faut savoir que naughty dog aime
faire des références et autres clins
d'oeil à ses futurs projets dans ces
jeux par exemple dans uncharted 3 dans
la scène du bar les joueurs avaient
repéré un easter egg sur un journal posé
sur le comptoir qui parlait d'une
maladie propagée
mais évidemment le journal parlait de
l'épidémie du cordyceps pareil pour une
charte id4 dans the last of us plusieurs
images de nathan drake sont présentés
dans le jeu mais notre attention sera
portée sur un calendrier situé dans une
maison qui fit référence à une charte
id4 même une date était indiquée octobre
et bizarrement un mois plus tard
l'annnonce de uncharted 4 sur ps4 fut
annoncée en novembre 2013
et bien maintenant vous allez devinez
passons à une charte id4 les joueurs ont
passé au peigne fin le jeu à la
recherche d' historique sur the last of
us 2 est bien un énorme indice a été
trouvé cette référence est disponible
dans le dernier chapitre de uncharted 4
la musique est un peu plus triste pour
faire référence à the last of us et un
médaillon des lucioles est accroché mais
ce n'est pas le plus intrigant sur un
mur nous pouvons distinguer un poster
avec le logo the last of us qui est très
reconnaissable mais ce qui nous permet
d'affirmer qu'une suite aura lieu et la
femme enceinte portant un masque à gaz
et un flingue dans la main bien
évidemment tout nous laisse penser que
cette femme serait elie que nous sommes
dans une suite de l'histoire principale
et kelly a donc grandi et deviendrait
mer mais quelque chose ne colle pas eli
est immunisée contre les sports elle n'a
jamais eu à porter de masque
ceux-ci casse vraiment la théorie qui
élit ai grandi nous pouvons lire en
dessous du logo du jeu american doubt
heures cela nous fait tout de suite
penser que la femme sur l'image serait
enceinte de jumeaux personnellement je
pense qu'il s'agirait d'une histoire du
passé
je rappelle que le contrôle joël vingt
ans plus tard eli a eu le temps de
naître de grandir et le monde c'est
entre guillemets reformer et survie face
à l'épidémie de la sto fuzz d'après
l'image parlerait pour moi de la merde
et
ana je ne pense pas que naughty dog
s'amuserait à créer vraiment une toute
nouvelle histoire sans avoir des
personnages liés à joël ou encore elie
l'histoire montrera elle périble de la
mer delhi avant qu'elle ne meure pour
sauver ses filles et que donc elie
posséderait un jumeau une soeur quelque
part dans le reste des états unis tout
ceci permettrait de créer une nouvelle
histoire tout en restant liés à nos bons
vieux joël elie auquel tout le monde
s'est attaché ce serait vraiment une
erreur que naughty dog ne fasse pas
mention de ceux ci
cette théorie se base avant tout pour
les joueurs qui pensent que joël a fait
un choix égoïste avec un fond mauvais
quand il a sauvé elie de l'opération
naughty dog dans the last of us nous
montrent comment l'humanité serait
devenu suite à une épidémie mortelle de
zombies les humains sont mis à rude
épreuve et doivent survivre face aux
infectés mais aussi face aux autres
humains beaucoup plus redoutable dans
cette totale anarchie joël survit tant
bien que mal depuis plus de 21 ans il a
perdu sa fille prématurément dans
l'histoire et il a failli perdre elie
qu'ils considèrent quasiment comme sa
propre fille
il se dope ses nerfs sont mises à
l'épreuve depuis plus de vingt ans le
savons d'ailleurs à quel point je l ai
durée peut être très agressif il a tué
énormément de monde afin de survivre
aucun être humain ne pourra encaisser
tout ce qu'il a fait et vécu où je veux
en venir c'est que pour n'importe quelle
raison joël pourrait être le méchant de
the last of us 2 voulant prendre sa
revanche sur les lucioles qui ont
cherché à le tuer maintes et maintes
fois
et pourtant je n'arrive pas à croire
cela à la fin du jeu on voit réellement
que joël souhaite enfin se poser avec
elie et faire sa vie tranquillement il
se pourrait plutôt que ça soit les
lucioles qui traquent joël pour
retrouver et lee et obtenir l'antidote
et venger marlène il se pourrait aussi
que joëlle esso velits simplement par
acte égoïste car il a perdu la raison
même si personnellement je ne le pense
pas et donc du coup eli apprenant la
nouvelle de son sauvetage qu'il joël et
se battra donc contre lui qui détraque
et souhaitera empêcher elie de faire ce
genre de choses
après tout ils disaient elie qu'elle
n'était pas le seul à être immunisé
pourquoi ne serait ce pas tout
simplement vrai pourquoi seulement elie
cependant personne ne peut prévoir la
suite de cela stoffel je ne savais pas
vraiment de quoi parler dans cette
dernière théorie car le jeu ne possède
pas réellement de grandes théories fondé
est réel à part la première que j'ai
écrite moi-même et la deuxième ce jeu
m'a énormément marqué quand je les fais
je pense qu'il faut aller plus loin que
ce que le genou
et ouvrir son esprit pour comprendre ses
nombreuses subtilités
je tiens à m'excuser de mon manque
d'activités mettant maintenant étudiants
et vivent hors de la maison familiale
les journées sont bien remplies entre
cours d'eau mystique et vie privée
n'hésitez pas à me proposer des idées
pour les prochains trois théories cet
argot rock que le liner soit avec vous